en pleine tempête après sa chanson on
polémique sur Paris Pierre Perret a
réagi il a fait une chanson en même
temps je peux comprendre si c'est baladé
un peu dans Paris on passe pour dire
c'est dégueulasse c'est encore
dégueulasse c'est un peu trop
cette chanson en fait il a pas voulu la
sortir au moment des élections et tout
ça pour parce que c'est pas anti-dalgo
c'est voilà il a pas voulu faire de
politique elle tombe très bien
[Musique]
dans Paris Paris dégoûtant
seuls les rats sont contents
pauvre Paris en Lady
dans quel état ils t'ont mis ils avaient
promis Nirvana
et c'est la Bérézina au Paris Paris en
lady
toi qui fut le paradis
te voilà fringues et Waterloo
car nous gentils écolos
alors ça a provoqué un tollé et
fortement critiqué
ou pas
Pierre Perret excusez-moi
vous militez pourquoi pour la France
d'avant la France d'Amélie Poulain et
dit la vérité
plutôt que de chanter comme ça
on se baladant sur
on se baladant sur un vélo dans un pari
de cartes postales mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce délire
on lui a pas imposé
d'avant
avec moi que Paris aujourd'hui regarde
moi je ne vis pas à Paris quand j'ai à
Paris c'est très beau Paris les gens qui
en a encore reconnais qu'avec tous ces
travaux alors aujourd'hui bon il y a les
poubelles mais tous ces travaux c'est
catastrophique quand même c'est pas le
pari et vous allez tous me dire c'est
pas le pari qu'on aime il est détruit
par il y a des travaux partout on ne
peut plus passer et maintenant il y a
les poubelles c'est triste c'est quand
même la plus belle parce qu'il y a une
grève
pour ne pas faire des chansons react
attention à ça quand même
défauts mais alors il y en a un qui n'a
pas c'est sûr et surtout pas rien alors
pourquoi il chante ça
regardez sa réaction
ce qui m'abuse c'est que j'entends tout
oh il tourne au vieux coups au vieux
c'est sûr au con j'en sais rien mais si
c'est tourné au vieux con mais voilà je
suis un vieux con mais au moins je dis
ce que j'ai à dire mais en même temps il
y a quand même beaucoup de gens qui me
plaisent merci
ah non
bravo bravo OK
la liberté d'expression oui monsieur
d'ailleurs je sais pas ramasser des
poubelles ça fonctionne pas du tout
réquisitionnés vont doucement
et puis de toute façon après c'est tout
le process puisque là où en achemine les
déchets les centres sont à moitié
paralysées ou fonctionnent doucement
donc c'est toute la tout le tout le
processus qui ne marche pas c'était pas
la peine de les réquisitionner dans mon
point de vue mais encore vous allez me
dire que je dis n'importe quoi
je laisse les gens faire la grève
maintenant il y a des rats il y a des
Arabes et vous pensez un peu aux
sans-abri qui sont qui sont dans la rue
tout le monde et aux éboueurs et aux
poussettes pour enfants moi quand je me
lève avec mon fils
c'est terrible c'est dramatique c'est
c'est je vois honnêtement je vois pas
l'argument pour ne pas c'est pas une
question de d'être engagé auprès c'est
juste une question de logique
l'intérêt l'intérêt collectif
excusez-moi c'est de protéger les
trottoirs les vieux les sans-abris les
oignons
c'est pareil c'est malheureusement tu
fais pas ce métier quand tu sais pas
quelle gouvernement public sur le public
donc Pierre Perret la paix vous savez
qu'il avait déjà fait le buzz avec au
moment du confinement avec une chanson
qui s'appelait les confinis et voilà et
Pierre Perret on se souvient de Lili sur
le racisme
grillagée sur les femmes voilées enfin
c'est quelqu'un qui hume l'air du temps
et voilà mais franchement
ça n'a rien à voir avec la grâce
de timing
il a fait plein de millions de vues et 1
million
et puis dis ce qu'il pense comme il a
dit c'est très bien de dire ce qu'on
pense
mais c'est comme la chanson le zizi
c'est à choqué ça toi ou quoi alors ça
n'a rien à voir
de retraite spirituelle c'est ça
depuis quelques mois
d'une manière un peu mignonnette et puis
dénoncer un peu des petites choses et
puis parler des choses un peu de filles
de manière mignonne donc Pierre Perret
on l'adore il est plus que jamais dans
l'air du temps moi je l'adore bravo sur
le zizi était bien venu mais justement
c'est ça ce que je voulais te poser
comme question agile je suis sûr qu'il y
a quelques années Gilles s'il y avait eu
l'émission il aurait dit oui c'est
inadmissible et tout la chanson c'est
exactement la même chose il a eu des
champions
comme les colonies de vacances ça paraît
anodin maintenant mais c'est autant de
génération
sur le net ce qu'il a fait il a fait des
très belles chansons
le zizi est une comptine très drôle
aussi voilà regardez les enfants les
c'est beau oui la bohème
le problème c'est pas lui non c'est pas
lui c'est pas lui
la liberté qui met en forme et c'est
très beau
et il le fait de manière très mignonne
de gens sur les réseaux sociaux qui sont
là avec moi
il faut des sécurités
on va faire un test qui pense en public
que cette chanson est un digne merci
donc une fois de plus comme d'habitude à
côté de la plaque et comme toujours à
côté de la plaque alors minorité on peut
pas dire quand même un peu à côté de la
plaque et merci beaucoup
et surtout ferme bien votre